the conditions up on Mount Charleston
right now not really ideal for anybody
who's looking for some outdoor activity
time especially on trails that don't see
much traffic and we saw some
yesterday when an avalanche took the
life of a skier the coroner has now
identified him as 32 year old poonan Zao
as the skier was caught in a back
country Avalanche Victoria Saha reports
as pretty as this may look a mother
nature comes with hidden dangers
on Monday five skiers went to back
country skiing on the mummy Trail in
Mount Charleston one of them got caught
in an avalanche this tragic accident is
a reminder
of the dangerous conditions that can
occur in the back country on Mount
Charleston Sergeant Matt Marlow with
Metro Police search and rescue say punan
Zao and two of his friends went to the
slopes where the Avalanche occurred the
remaining two were not in the way Mr
zao's friends were able to locate him
by his Personal Locator Beacon his
friends called Mount Charleston fire and
started to carry Zao down the mountain
one search and rescue officials got
there they did CPR for 30 minutes but
Zao died according to Jonathan Stein the
recreation manager for spring mountains
Avalanches are rare in southern Nevada
but do happen we've had lighter less
moisture content snow
we do we did have a period of time where
it was very cold with no snowfall and
that can contribute to weak layers Stein
says there weren't any Avalanche
forecasts for Mount Charleston like
other parts of the country but he says
the weather around can be a good
indicator if there could be an avalanche
similar to the weather we had Monday and
Tuesday
he also says the area where the skiers
went was not closed off we always check
out the conditions first we never really
commit to going out we kind of check it
out on our way out we try and stay warm
I wear like ice cleats on my shoes so I
don't try and slip and fall the U.S
forest Service says they will now call a
national experts to investigate this
Avalanche the last time there was a
deadly Avalanche here was back in 2005.
reporting in Mount Charleston Victoria
Saha 8 news now you heard that
individual there mentioned ice clates
also personal Beacon locators highly
encouraged for hikers and skiers going
out in the winter weather so are probes
you can use them with beacons to find
people buried by an avalanche and if
you're going into a risky spot learn how
to spot some of the warning signs of
avalanches in that Terrain